i'm the doctor i'll be your victim this
evening are you my mummy
[Music]
mummy on the orient express
i have been so excited
to get back to this one it's it's been
too long since i've rewatched it front
to back
it's so good it is so
good the premise the pacing
the performances the central conceit the
resolution
it is so good
it is a wonderful mix of an incredibly
campy pre premise yet treating it
seriously because honestly the title
mummy on the orient express that should
be right up there with dinosaurs on a
spaceship
which i actually like that episode but
it does lead more into sort of the camp
nature that you'd expect from a title
like that this doesn't this treats it
quite a bit more seriously without being
overly
dour or maudlin it's but it's taking
a preposterous premise of a mummy
on the orient express
in space
it just runs with it i love this episode
it's absolute gold and this is mainly
gonna be just me gushing
like know that understand that that's
what will happen
from pretty much here on out right from
the beginning
i love that it opens with start the
clock
and we see the that is a brilliant touch
by the way the fact that the counter
is on screen the whole time that first
of all that beats the heck
out of the traditional cut to a counter
just have it there
is there an actual reason why it's there
is there a diegetic reason why i said
no who cares you watch
the time tick away not by cutting away
from the action
but right in the corner of your vision
the whole time it's right there
plus i really love that they had the
tenths of a second
in addition because the doctor
solved it after it had rolled over to
zero but there were tenths of a second
left
zero and now see normally solving
something
that close to the wire i would scoff and
be like god of course but you know what
it works when you've been watching that
counter go down the whole time
where it doesn't work is they're working
on something they're working on
something they solve it you cut to a
timer and there was one second left
even if they time the edit of the thing
where
it is in real time however long it was
said to be
that's still not going to work for me
but here
being there feeling the tension as the
clock
winds down and you're watching it wind
down
genius and like i said they don't even
bother trying to justify why the counter
is there they just put it up
and they put it up before you even know
what it is
perfect because that there are times
where you break the rules you put in
something that you don't have an
in-universe reason for having because
it makes the story better that clock
makes the story better so not only do i
love that clock i love
that that is the cold open that is how
we start i
enjoy the execution of the vibe
of this being a last trip in theory
now i did mention at the la at the end
of the previous
review that it frustrated me that after
this
big blow up between the doctor and clara
that she just goes on one more trip with
him and i think i said something to the
effect of if somebody is that
hurtful to you and you feel that they've
abused you emotionally that much you
don't go on
effectively one more date that's not
healthy
i had forgotten that somebody calls
clara out on that i forget the name of
the woman
that she's with for most of this story
but
that woman does you know clara says you
know one more go
you know how it is she's like no people
don't do that
not if they're really planning to leave
so i'm
relieved that it was brought up in
episode because if it wasn't commented
upon
that would have really bothered me so
even though i still
feel like it's a little off
coming immediately off of the end of
kill the moon and that
big argument scene i they do at least
acknowledge it which i did not remember
and that helps part of what i like about
the whole one final trip
angle of it is there's a really
for lack of a better way to put it sweet
awkwardness
between the doctor and clara where
neither of them is quite sure how to
behave
because this is you know another
adventure for them but it's also
supposed to be the last one
should we be doing this differently
should we be behaving as if it isn't
going to be the last time and that
awkwardness
permeates their early scenes together
and that's really well done
the guest cast in this one is also
really
really good highlight for me is perkins
the engineer like he's he's one of those
characters that's so good i'm like
if you had tagged along and become a
companion i would have been totally good
with it
i i like that he is intelligent
and quick-witted but also very
blue-collar
a very you know lower decks kind of a
personality
and it's he's just so
good interacting with capaldi he's not
the only good performance though the the
guy who's the
professor who knows about the foretold
he's quite good and
quite a dynamic performance as well as
he
you know he sees this thing he sees this
thing coming towards him and he knows
what it is and he's trying to be helpful
he's trying to relay the information
he's trying to hold it together but he
cracks
and even though he knows all the stories
he knows that the begging the bargaining
none of it works and he does it anyways
it's very human and then contrasting
that with the captain
who does hold it together and the
captain has a history of
has an acknowledged history of ptsd so
you would think he'd be the more likely
one to crack
but instead he knuckles down and he
relays as much information as he can
right up to the end i love that
i actually i tend to forget
about him but i actually rather like gus
that's the computer i really like
the vocal performance on him there's
something
i use the same comparison when talking
about the um
the robots in uh
dinosaurs on the spaceship i'm making
more comparisons to that one
than i would have expected um where
the the way that he speaks which is he's
still very
functional as a computer as a machine
in terms of what he's doing but he has
this
intonation and this personality in the
way that he says it that feels very
douglas adams
to me and i really like that because i
feel like
more often than not when robots or
machines or computers are given
personalities they're then basically
treated as if they're human
and they behave as if they were human
whereas here
the computer behaves very
computer like very robotic but the
delivery in the voice
has a little personality has a little
inflection
thank you very much for your assistance
you know that sort of dry announcements
on a
train voice but just with a little bit
of personality injected i really do like
it
i also really love uh like especially
now
knowing that
the doctor is going to become more
personable
during capaldi's run and that he is
going to loosen up over time
knowing that this is not going to be how
he is forever
i am able to enjoy much more than i did
upon first viewing
the fact that the doctor is pragmatic to
the point of being
very very cold and very unfeeling
like he knows these people are going to
die he's not going to comfort them
he's not going to lie to them he's not
even going to pretend that he's choked
up about it he accepts it as a given
they're going to die how can they help
so maybe other people don't
that level of pragmatism from him
makes a lot of sense for this doctor
particularly at this stage
in his tenure and i like the way it's
played
because even though he kind of shuts off
his own emotions the determination is
still there
he doesn't he doesn't not
care but he accepts immediately
when something's already a lost cause he
doesn't rail against it
he accepts it instantly which is a
little bit different
from the doctor to be that pragmatic
because there have been other
incarnations of the doctor who are very
much the
there's always a way i'll find a way
there has to be something and then if it
goes wrong they get very upset
whereas this doctor i mean basically
someone seemed before told is things
going wrong that person's going to die
and he just takes that as a given well
okay i can't save you but please help
and not even uh with much of a bedside
manner
which i i think gets noted by i think by
the captain
calls him out on his bedside banner and
actually since i mentioned the captain
let's talk about something that
given my frustration with this element
in this series up to this point i was
surprised how well it worked here
and i think it it really does show the
difference in level of the execution
episode to episode
the element of soldiers
because we've had that as a recurring
thing the doctor keeps encountering
soldiers
over and over again and he's very
dismissive
and rude to them whether they be
danny or the people in into the dialect
he's just he has no time for soldiers he
seems to have no respect
for soldiers but he does show a measure
of respect
towards the captain who used to be
soldier
and he shows a level of
understanding and remorse towards
the foretold the mummy upon realizing
that
it's a soldier loaded up with tech
that won't let it die
and this is integrating the thematic
how the doctor relates to soldiers and
military people
way better and with so much more nuance
because this is a case where both of the
people who
are or were soldiers are problems at
various points
the captain is initially an obstacle the
captain initially
tries to stop the doctor from looking
into it now he comes
to in his own words like three it's
three people have to die before i start
taking you seriously
and then he just goes forward but he is
initially an obstacle
and obviously the foretold being a
soldier that is it's effectively
the villain of the piece but
both are treated with a lot more nuance
by the doctor
not just by the story by the doctor
and this is weaving these themes and
these recurring elements
so much better so that it's not coming
off as this clunky
uh soldiers the thing that it's been
most the times has come up in this
series
which is it has been so frustrating for
me
like you've seen me get really worked up
about that so it was funny to see it
turn up here in a way that like not only
am i okay with i think is really well
done
so i think it shows there wasn't
necessarily an inherent
problem with the concept of the doctor
having a
complicated or adversarial relationship
with soldiers
it's just it was not done well in the
instances where it came up prior to this
we'll see if it gets done well in other
instances after this
so after all this gushing do i have any
nitpicks do i have anything that
doesn't quite work yes
although one thing isn't necessarily the
fault of this episode the other one i'm
not even sure is
necessarily a bad thing but i don't like
it
so even these criticisms are very soft
criticism
the first is while i like gus and i
mentioned that
the doctor says you know he's trying to
figure out who sent gus or who
who initialized him or something like
that and we don't find out in this
episode and
to my memory and a very brief admittedly
google search that never pays off
so that was i don't know if it was
something that was supposed to and they
never
circled back to it or decided it wasn't
worth doing
or if there was just an assumption oh
maybe we'll do something with that later
they just never did but
it ends up being a dangling plot thread
that doesn't go anywhere
not that i necessarily needed it to that
wasn't a burning question in my mind
why gus uh when you know went for the
doctor or how he knew
who the doctor was i don't necessarily
need answers to that so i'm not mad at
it for being an unanswered question i'm
annoyed at it for bringing it up
if nothing was going to be done with
that later the other thing that
frustrates me
has a bit to do with clara so at the
front end
i really liked that clara
spoke to danny on the phone danny knew
where she was
i liked that interaction
but then by contrast
i really hate that at the end
she lies to him
and to the doctor she tells
danny yeah that was definitely my last
trip i'm definitely
done and then tells the doctor
danny said it's okay for me to keep
traveling with you she has now lied to
both of them she is now effectively
not romantically but effectively as far
as
breakage of trust goes cheating on danny
with the doctor
and the doctor doesn't know that he is
now the other man
that she is spending time with that she
isn't supposed to be
so she is she is lying and being
deceptive and cheating on danny
again like i don't mean romantically i
mean in terms of
the kind of breach of trust it is
effectively cheating on danny
and is making the doctor unknowingly
complicit
in that and that's not necessarily a bad
thing if from a writing standpoint
but it does make me hate clara
again i didn't like clara in series 7
because she was under characterized she
was more of a plot point than a
character
i was liking her in series eight because
they developed rosy character they
they properly characterized her and i
liked that characterization now
this is still characterizing here so now
she's not under characterized but the
characterization they've now decided to
the direction to take her in i don't
like her as a person now
and part of that is my own baggage and
my own
feelings and comfort level with watching
somebody
knowingly deceive their romantic partner
the way that she's doing
that's not a comfortable thing for me
personally to watch and it's really not
comfortable
if it's a character that you actually
want me to
like and to sympathize with
because i don't because at this point
she is
she has made the decision to hurt danny
that is a choice she has made and yet
you can make whatever argument you want
well she thinks he won't find out what
it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter if she thinks she's
gonna get away with it in her mind she's
do some
she's doing something that she knows
will hurt him
whether he ever finds out or not she has
made the choice
to hurt him and that makes me not like
her
as a person and that
that kind of puts me back at ground zero
with clara again
and there was progress being made
in terms of me you know liking her a bit
more
oh well mommy on the orient express
still a phenomenal episode what do you
think about it have you rewatched it
lately whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments
let's talk about it usual stuff you know
what it is i've got a patreon that's
kind of the big one it helps
keep the lights on and ensure that i can
eat
but even if you're not able to do that
liking subscribing commenting and
sharing this video
are all helpful so that would be greatly
appreciated but
you don't have to do any of it
i would appreciate it but at the end of
the day you're at the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]